an uncommon sight in the city of buenos
aires tractors from across the country
came to argentina's capital to protest
against the government of alberto
fernandez
andrej miles traveled from the province
of santa fe he explained why he and
others like him are at risk
we cannot produce like this all of us
end up renting our farms because
small-scale farmers end up renting their
land to international corporations who
can afford to bear the enormous tax
burden we have
food prices are rising worldwide driven
up by the war in ukraine this has put
argentinian producers on alert farmers
say taxes export taxes drought and
exchange rate controls are hurting their
capacity to produce and fear the
government could increase taxes even
more
thousands of people accompanied the
farmers to the center of the city to
protest against the administration of
alberto fernandez they say they're tired
of the inflation rate it was close to
seven percent last month and of the
difficulties they face every month
they're saying that the government has
no economic plan and the bureaucracy and
the restrictions implemented by the
administration are hurting argentina's
productive sector
last march the government increased
export taxes on soybean flour and oil
seeking to control local prices and
stabilize the price of wheat to what it
was before ukraine's conflict
it also says farmers are overreacting
and there are no plans to increase
export taxes again at least for now
we have an increased export taxes on the
producers so they are marching just in
case they're marching against the
project they don't know or imagine that
could happen so we have no doubt this is
a political demonstration that has to do
with other interests than defending the
rights of the farmers
journalists like mattia longoni say the
situation inflames already long-running
tensions between the government and the
agricultural sector
the farming sector's in a strange
situation because like most countries in
the world where they produce more food
than they consume there's a chance to
make profit
argentina has a surplus of food and it
could export more grain milk and meat
but in argentina's case the better
prices don't always benefit the farmer
this is the constant trouble between
producers and the government
and that's why farmers vow to continue
with their demands
they say government assistance would
help them to produce more something they
say would benefit argentina's economy
and the whole world
perishable al jazeera buenos aires